Cinderella is directed by Kenneth
Branagh and is a live-action adaptation
of Cinderella we all know about
Cinderella but for those of you who do
not know the story of Cinderella there
are some of you out there I'm sure it's
about a young girl who's very courageous
and very kind as taught to her by her
mother when her mother and father both
are out of the picture she's raised by a
very evil stepmother and two stepsisters
who keep her locked in the Attic and
force her to do nothing but basically
slave work for the rest of her life
until the night she meets her fairy
godmother it has given an opportunity to
be someone that she isn't I'm not gonna
lie
not a single bone in my body was
anticipating this movie in fact when I
heard about another Cinderella
adaptation I was like I'm gonna have to
watch that I was just thinking why does
this movie have to actually happen I
mean do we really need another
Cinderella movie when you can just go
and watch the original animated film
that's great still to my surprise this
movie is actually good and so I'm dumb
there aren't really any chance as taken
with the source material it's the same
Cinderella you knew and loved before
it's just told and the best way it could
in the most grounded way they could
while still maintaining the Disney magic
of the original everyone in the movie is
giving respectable performances the
shots all look great the movie is
directed about as good as it could be
this is the kind of movie that young
kids especially girls will love but
adults can come and actually watch and
still find enjoyment in it because it's
not childish there's a lot of emotion
thrown into this film that doesn't feel
superficial the emotion is all well
realized in the performances in the
script and in the direction and normally
when a kid is being really annoying or
loud or talkative in a theater it gets
on my nerves during this film there was
a young girl who was sitting in front of
me who actually stood up and kind of put
her arms on the seat in front of her and
whenever something happened that was in
any way magical she would go and look at
her mom now I thought that was probably
the most adorable thing I've ever seen
in my life so young kids as I said
especially girls are really gonna get a
kick out of this movie it's gonna touch
them and it's not gonna teach them
anything that they shouldn't know
because yes there is that theme of she
gets everything that she wants and she
gets noticed because she's given a
a bunch of magical powers that give her
things that aren't real but as you know
in the classic cinderella story it's
about accepting a person for who they
are and not because of some title or
because of a whole bunch of riches or
objects that they own and that is a
great message for kids and Cinderella
retains that and it tells it in a
respectable way as for flaws there's
nothing new here I mean there really is
not a single surprise it's just by the
numbers Disney fair but it's all really
well done
Disney Fair Cate Blanchet is great as
the stepmother Lily James is excellent
as Cinderella all the actors do really
well it's just that there isn't anything
that's mind-blowing or different or
original or groundbreaking about
Cinderella and you don't really need it
to be I think this is going to bring
Cinderella to a new and modern
generation of kids in a good way for
that reason I'm going to give Cinderella
a B surprise surprise because not a
single part of me wanted to see this
movie but I ended up enjoying myself
speaking of adaptations the original
book Cinderella is currently available
on audible.com and I'm still doing a
promotion with them as I have been now
for I believe over a year that promotion
through audible was my way of giving you
guys something free it's a free
audiobook download if you'd like it you
can have it audible.com slash Chris
that's all you need to know if you go to
that link you can have a free audiobook
download of your choice like the
original Cinderella book which is
included on audible.com that's it
free enjoy it and try to find promotions
that I could actually do in my channel
that gives you guys free cool stuff and
I hope you guys visit audible.com slash
Chris because that's my gift to you guys
enjoy and thank you so much as always
for watching I greatly appreciate it and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes